[Musik]
mathias richling ist einer der
bekanntesten kabarettisten deutschlands
und er ist unbestritten deutschlands
bester parodist von angela merkel über
donald trump bis hin zu karl lauterbach
keiner verkörpert so treffend so witzig
und auch so entlarvend die großen
wichtigen und mächtigen dieser welt
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
persönlich ja vielen dank das war zu
viel aber nur das passte nicht
unterbrechen
doch nicht nur das beste für unsere
gäste wie sind sie denn durch die korona
krise gekommen bisher das ganze ja ja
ich persönlich darf mich nicht
beschweren weil ich bin gott sei dank
keine 20 mehr keine 25
das heißt in dieser zeit die ich arbeite
habe ich ein paar rücklagen geschaffen
die allmählich auch zu ende gehen aber
was mich noch viel mehr belastet ist
eben die zunehmende depression von
kollegen oder freunden die eben im
kleinkaliber sehen und gastronomen
künstler
das ist das ist sehr schwierig werden
sie gehören zu den glücklichen wenn ich
das so sagen darf sie haben eine
regelmäßige fernsehshow beim svr die
mathias richling schau einmal im monat
aber wie geht es denen die eben den
künstlerinnen den künstlern die dieses
fernseh stand bei nicht haben die jetzt
nicht auftreten können ja katastrophal
also ich muss auch sagen ich habe auch
70 vorstellung absagen müssen im letzten
jahr oder bis heute und die es gibt
viele schauspieler kollegen
ich habe einen mit kleinen theatern
gesprochen wo die sagen 30 prozent
unserer kollegen
werden putzfrau straßenkehrer oder
einfach obdachlos war und diese dieses
problem wird noch immer haben dafür hat
nochmal eine beobachtung eben in
keinster weise berücksichtigt was mir
fehlt ist eben oder was allen fehlt ist
das eine ist das was herr schäuble schon
im juni letzten jahres gesagt hat und
jetzt im januar schon wieder nicht nur
man kann nicht jeden retten soll sagte
auch das leben ist eben nicht nur
gesundheit es gibt auch die soziale
wirtschaftliche psychologische
gesundheit oder psychische gesundheit
und diese beratungsgremien werden
überhaupt nicht zugelassen
in dem großen gipfel und das schafft das
eigentliche problem dass erst kommen
wird wenn man mit dem deckmantel der
kurzarbeit die dann aufhört nach der
bundestagswahl sind für sinnvoller weise
in anführungsstrichen da wenn das dann
zu viel obdachlosen in den in dem
einzelhandel viertel in dem kleid bei
den kleinen sohn soll
ich versuche mir mal zu überlegen was
was angela merkel ihnen entgegnen will
die würde mut muss ich sagen wir haben
täglich 300 tote wir haben die virus
mutationen da kann man eben nicht blind
öffnen da gut also
nun muss man sagen es fixiert oder ich
mir fällt dazu eine talkshow von neulich
ein wo ein politiker sagte wir wollen
nicht dass menschen sterben und der
moderator sagte sie wollen nicht dass
sie an corinna sterben und ich sage an
allem anderen dürfen sie verrecken
denn wir haben in deutschland 2009 nur
tote am tag das ist die normale
sterbequote man kann gut jetzt wenn wir
noch 300 das so wie ich nicht sagen aber
die fixierung da drauf ist einfach auch
nach einem jahr für mich der ich mich
intensiv damit beschäftigt habe
irrational also ich kann es nicht nach
denn ja ich verstehe nicht ganz warm ist
dass die rational waren sich darauf
fixiert und sagt das sind jetzt 70.000
menschen in deutschland zusätzlich
gestorben warum ist das irrational weil
ich dann frage sehen sie wir haben auf
der welt im jahr 1,5 millionen toter im
verkehr ist das nicht
warum schließen wir die autobahn nicht
warum schaffen wir die autos nicht ab
wir haben eine
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung wir haben
sicherheit falls wir haben genau auf die
todes quote auf den autobahnen hat sich
drastisch gesenkt ist jetzt bleiben
trotzdem in deutschland 3000 im jahr
aber nicht mal aus beispiel es ist was
wir nie vergleichen dürfen ich weiß es
schon ich weiß corinna ist sehr viel
gefährlicher und man weiß die
spätwirkungen nicht und so weiß ich
alles
trotzdem nehmen wir nochmal dieses
beispiel von vor zwei jahren die
berühmte virusgrippe die die impfung hat
nicht ganz funktioniert weil eben dem
die mutation schon weiter gegangen war
zehn millionen infizierte hatte in
deutschland und 25.000 eine tote in vier
monaten
warum haben wir da nicht ein kiosk
geschlossen waren die nichts wert waren
die weniger wert als crooner tote heute
also drehen wir einfach die
argumentation um bin gern dafür
natürlich kann man muss man jeden
schützen selbst verständlich warum ist
das nicht geschehen so ich weiß zum
beispiel von von kamera kollegen die da
oder moderation kollegen die damals
einen betrag beitrag machen wollten zu
der virusgrippe und das wurde einfach
nicht gewünscht um keine panik
herzustellen und diese paniksituation
die erreicht wird bei aller
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ist natürlich auch
dadurch hergestellt in das team
maßnahmen irrational sind als beispiel
ja ich bin sehr um das gleich zu ich bin
sehr für maske und bin sehr für abstand
ich finde das ganz fürchterlich wenn ich
im restaurant sitze und die nächsten
leute setzen sie direkt neben mich da
setze ich mich weg ich habe gesagt ich
mache keine grippe finde ich wunderbar
aber ich bin sehr dafür tragen eine
maske auch die nächsten 20 jahre wenn es
sein muss mit corinna links hoffentlich
vorbei ist so aber es gibt dann so
maßnahme aus dem letzten jahr zum
beispiel dass man sagt okay ist ein
kinderspielplatz ab geflattert mit dem
flatterband unternehmens ist an der alte
frau alleine und liest ein buch muss
eine strafe zahlen
und das haben wir ja wieso kommt das
virus aus der bank kommt es durch die
luft da werden hysterisch und panische
reaktionen hervorgerufen weil man sich
das nicht erklären kann
darf ich mal der einheit also wir halt
mal fest sein business hysterisch und
spanisch dann würde ich gleich darauf
eingegangen
zunächst mal dieser vergleich mit der
krippe ok ja eingeräumt die die grippe
hat
viele tote gekostet aber es gibt ja noch
zwei entscheidende unterschiede
erstens gegen grippe kann man sich
impfen und es gibt genügend impfstoff
gab es bisher nicht
und gegen grippe gibt es auch
arzneimittel deswegen eben die
sterblichkeit bei grippe geringer ist
das sind doch entscheidende unterschiede
die für den einzelnen im zweifelsfall
den unterschied zwischen leben und tod
ausmachen können deswegen ist eben der
vergleich mit krippe in aller regel sagt
man nicht derjenige der zu treffen
treffend es teilweise weil warum gab es
denn zehn millionen infizierte bei der
grippe vor zwei jahren wurde vor drei
inzwischen weil eben dem stoff doch
nicht gewirkt hat wie er sollte und es
bleibt dann trotzdem dabei fehler sich
nicht geimpft haben es impfen sich gegen
grippe ich glaube 80 prozent der
bevölkerung haben sich nicht gegen
grippe impfen lassen aber sie hätten tun
können dass mir auf dass sie sagen das
ist panisch dass es übertrieben war
warum glauben sie dass das panischen
übertrieben weil die division
zum glück ist ja das was ich seit einem
jahr sage inzwischen immer mehr in der
öffentlichkeit und auch von seriösen
beobachtern so beschrieben das heißt die
reaktive die maßnahmen sind oft eben
nicht logisch also nicht nachvollziehbar
wenn die nur als beispiel also gut
klarerweise sind die supermärkte offen
damit man auch sich was zu essen kauft
kann so rest der kleine restaurants die
ein sie eine sicherheitsvorkehrung
gemacht haben im bis zum herbst letzten
jahres die exorbitant war die mit jetzt
vielleicht zwei drei tische haben die
sie bedienen sondern wie so können die
nicht öffnen
gegen beide also
in der argumentation weiter lothar
wieler der chef des robert koch
institutes und potenzieller neuer
bundeskanzler war ja auch jeden tag
seine regierungserklärung abgibt hat im
oktober letzten jahres in der
ankündigung des doktors von november
gesagt also die ansteckung im
theatermuseum gaststätten sind um die
fünf prozent dazu gibt es auch eine
grafik dazu und etwa 50 bis 60 im
privaten bereich
wir schließen theatergasse hingesehen
und schicken die leute im privaten
bereich was soll ich ohne irgendwelche
fürchterlichen sachen zu vermuten
wie soll ich das interpretieren also
sollen die leute krank so das meine ich
mit panik schaffen wie wiso schicke ich
die leute aus einem relativ ich habe mir
selber gespielt im oktober in berlin
wir hatten eine sicherheitsmaßnahme ist
unglaublich 15 quadratmeter umgebungen
wo kann wo die wörter allein es mussten
jeder musste eines theater betreten mit
maske und allen daten zu hatte es gab da
keine hot spots also wieso schließt mit
yoga store in verschiedenen ich versuche
sie zu versteigern
aber ich versuche auch die andere seite
zu verstehen das sind also jetzt die
künstler die dürfen nicht auftreten
sagen bei uns steckt man sich nicht an
da sind die schüler und viele lehrer die
sagen wir haben tolle maßnahmen in der
schule steckt man sich nicht an
da gibt es die gastronomen ja die sagen
bei uns ist alles in ordnung da steckt
man sich nicht an und ich könnte jetzt
die ganzen gesellschaftlichen bereiche
durchmachen alle sagen wir sind es nicht
ans handy
lassen sie mich das am ende haben wir
eine regierung haben wir
ministerpräsidenten haben wir eine
kanzlerin die eben dafür sorgen muss
dass diese pandemie nicht außer
kontrolle gerät würden sie denn diese
abwägt diese schwierige abwägung
zwischen gesundheit und freiheit der
bürger würden sie die prinzipiell anders
treffen
das ist eine general frage die man so
mit einem jahr oder nicht beantworten
kann denn dazu gehören ein paar
prämissen ich sage es nochmal ich berufe
mich new prinzipiell nur auf die
informationen die vom rk yao
weltgesundheitsorganisation und nicht
irgendwelche unterstellungen als
die grundinformationen seit einem jahr
vom rk ii ist und auch für die von
vielen instituten innsbrucker institut
über ischgl und und andere institute
sagen um die 85 prozent der infizierten
haben keine symptome so das muss ich so
glauben ich kann es nicht gegen
kontrollieren aber das ist das was ich
überall erfahren
so liegt die sterbequote ist um 0,2
prozent jetzt werden sie sagen zwei
millionen tote auf der welt ja zwei
millionen tote zu 7,8 milliarden
menschen sind 0,01 prozent tut mir leid
also ich würde mal gerne einlagen also
das sind 0,2 prozent sterbequote die
würden viele experten so nicht stehen
lassen
da gibt es viele viele studien also
deutlich höheren sterbezahlen kommen
will ich jetzt mithin der maximale
sortieren naja es gibt es das weiß ich
zwei prozent auf 4 prozent
so hätten wir fest wäre die sterbequote
60% fasse ich sie an und sie kriegen die
beulen nein und das ist da ist der
leidensdruck in der gesellschaft nicht
groß genug wie viele leute kennen sie
die kuh ich weiß wer corona hatte das
ist ein furchtbares wenn sie wollen
verrecken und man es gibt einen aus
amerika der die letzten anderthalb
minuten eines corona sterbenden nach
simuliert hat also wie zeitung dann
hätte ich auch gern die letzten
anderthalb minuten eines sterbenden
gesehen gestern haben ich und eines
sterbenden oder eines
lungenkrebs sterben usw das ist das
nenne ich hysterisierung natürlich ist
das schlimm für die dies betrifft aber
insgesamt 483 millionen nur 460
millionen europäer ist der leidensdruck
nicht groß genug und das nachsehen
das ist ein jahr lang alle
eingeschlossen oder alles das soziale
und kulturelle leben nicht möglich ist
jetzt letztendlich muss diese
gesellschaft bus deutschland ja in einer
demokratischen debatte entscheiden
welche maßnahmen wie viele maßnahmen
ergreifen wir um diese pandemie wir
durchstehen wieviel
freiheitsbeschränkung akzeptieren wir
und wieviel schäden an gesundheit und
leben nehme in kauf bisher hat eine
überwiegende überwältigende mehrheit der
bevölkerung gesagt ja der kurs den
angela merkel und die
ministerpräsidenten da fahren das ist
der richtige bisher hatten war er mehr
leute die sagen wir wollen schärferen
block dann als solche die wie sie sagen
nein das ist mir zu freiheitsberaubung
kam auf bisher erst einmal zu
warum ganz logisch wenn sie angst
verbreiten egal wie dann haben sie die
leute immer auf ihrer seite und angst
hat mich jemand warum glauben sie denn
sollte eine regierung sollten angela
merkel und den ministerpräsidenten wider
besseres wissen angst verbreiten oder
die experten und wieder ich bin doch
inzwischen nicht der einzige der sagten
seriöse menschlich wiederholt es noch
mal herr schäuble hat gerade es wieder
gesagt die die kollateralschäden
kollateral toten werden überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt und das werden sehr viel
mehr sein als diejenigen die lieber
corona gestorben sind wenn herr schäuble
sagt es der die welthungerhilfe erwartet
millionen hungertote weil die bauern
nicht saatgut anbauen können und liefern
können usw
mir geht es nur um dieses wort
kollateral tod des new york der eine
oder andere jetzt missverstehen ich
versuche zu verstehen was politiker sind
habe ich nicht politik gefragt sein
es sterben unter umständen menschen so
versteht sie auch an den folgendes
lockdown sei habe sie da richtig
verstanden
und das ist ja doch auch naheliegend
erstens habe ich gerade einen menschen
gesprochen deren anwalt kennt wo ich
zwei mandanten sich umgebracht haben
dass man es eine es gibt auch leute die
nicht behandelt werden oder sich nicht
ins krankenhaus trauen wegen
herzbeschwerden wegen krebs ich kenne
jemanden und das ist das da bin ich
nicht der das wort kollateralschaden
erfunden hat dazu bitte ja ja ich möchte
generell ist trotzdem etwas was ist denn
jetzt die sagen wir mal letztendlich das
ziel dessen visier argumentieren
glauben sie wir müssen anders abwägen
wir müssen mehr gesundheitliche schäden
in kauf nehmen damit wir mehr es ist ja
auch sagt dass jeder dritte satz beginnt
waren wieder wir wissen nicht genau
und so war wissen wir es hier auch nicht
also wir haben den lockt an seit
november hat sich wirklich die quote
erheblich gesenkt jetzt können sie nur
werden sie mir gleich sagen ja sie hat
sich erhöht ja schon okay aber sie
wissen es genauso wenig wie das andere
es gibt es wissen nicht wie viele tote
es geben würde wenn keinerlei maßnahmen
ergriffen worden werden aber es gibt
doch das ein oder andere dinge was
wollen sie alles sagen würde es gibt
doch das eine oder andere land auf
dieser erde dass andere wege versucht
hat von schweden bis usa und die zahl
der toten pro kopf der bevölkerung sind
in aller regel doch höher als in
deutschland deutschland ist ja bisher
war ich werde eine kleine anwendung
machen weil ich möchte wirklich nicht
ins eigentlich in eine psychiatrische
klinik gehören der herren trump in
schutz im ganz bestimmt nicht aber wir
haben sie wissen vielleicht die
aktuellen zahlen wie viele tote gab es
in einem gibt es bis heute in amerika
über corona also meine letzte zahl ist
um die 400 millionen 400.000 schulden so
viel hat amerika ganz schön also sag mal
400.000 wurde zu meinem letzten
informationsstand ist ein paar wochen
her waren 360.000 und wie viel hat
europa in derselben zeit etwa 380
400.000 der ist richtig aber das liegt
daran weil bestimmung länder wie
frankreich italien spanien besonders
viele tote
amerika 335 millionen einwohner und wir
haben 65 millionen ist es prozentual wie
sie es verteilen okay aber es ist
derselbe wert
sie haben besser durch die krise
gekommen als die usa und das zweite ist
wir haben
ich sage ja nicht dass man nichts
dagegen machen soll ich betone es noch
mal viele maßnahmen sind findet sich
sehr für mich persönlich auch sehr
sinnvoll wie maske und abstand wunderbar
aber es gibt eben dinge die es sind es
gibt auch beispiele münster rostock
tübingen boris palmer der es anders löst
unser oder andere lösungsmöglichkeiten
hat und der eben mir geht es nicht in
erster linie darum gehen wird von den
massen so etwas was ist die zusätzliche
belastung die leute wissen sie wenn sie
ich sage es nochmal der leidensdruck ist
nicht groß genug und das können sie das
bricht jetzt auf seit ein paar wochen
rechtes auf die leute können wir wenn
sie haben bisher war die mehrheit der
menschen für noch mehr locker und die
letzte wertig 57 prozent dagegen
und je mehr die leute sie unter anderen
dingen leiden also durchaus unter grüner
umso mehr wird es der gegenproteste
geben
ich würde jetzt an der stelle gerne ein
drama wenn ich weiter komme ich sehe
schon genau weil sie sind ja nun
kabarettist aber damit will ich ja nicht
weg leiten vom thema corona sondern sie
setzen sich ja auch mit
kabarettistischen mitteln mit dem thema
corona außerdem eine ganz wichtige rolle
bei dieser krise spielen die experten
und die sollen natürlich in dieser
sendung auch zu wort kommen karl
lauterbach bitte das ist natürlich eine
innovative ich kann es nur ein überholen
keine kontakte kontakte keine kontakte
keine kontakte keine kontakte können es
ist ja wir brauchen mehr getrennte
schlafzimmer
wir brauchen wir schon
brauchen wir singlehaushalte hin der
dafür nur noch aufbewahrt werden in
luftdichten räumen
der mensch muss ein einzeller werden
wir dürfen es nur noch vermehren durch
selbst befruchtung und das ist ein jahr
millionen langer evolutionsprozess aber
bei schnecken funktioniert es ja auch
wir müssen den verein sehen nicht
arbeiten nicht bewegen nicht sprechen
nicht atmen nicht essen das ist einfach
die gesundheits wollen sollen ja die es
reichte aber aus anderen sendungen
kriegt man sie nicht raus aus dieser
schon tschüs karl lauterbach nicht
gerade schneider fern lauterbach haben
sie was gegen lauterbach oder gegen
korona experten als sie ihn haben dort
auch ein chor ohne experten ich nehme es
zur kenntnis
also das problem was offensichtlich ist
man lauterbach er hat von der spd nie
ein ministeramt ministeramt angeboten
bekommen jetzt schlägt er zurück
deswegen ist jetzt 15 mal in der woche
in irgendwelchen talkshows und verbreite
sich da ist genau dieser effekt dass das
was zusätzliche gesundheit ich sage es
noch einmal die psychologische die
psychische gesundheit ist mindestens so
wichtig und wenn man einen kleinen
hoffnungsschimmer kommt aber gleich
dahinter hängen sagt jetzt konnte die
tabelle und das kommt die vier tabelle
und wir müssen eigentlich im grunde
genommen gibt es so viel gefahren wir
wissen jetzt kommt der nächste schnupfen
da wissen wir auch die wieder ausgesagt
im grunde müsste es eigentlich einen
permanenten nie endenden lockdown geben
und das ist das was die leute nicht
ertragen ganz einfach wie so gefährlich
wie es wie es sein mag und ist dass auf
dieser basis wie lauterbach hat seine
befürworter und seine gegner er war
übrigens interessanterweise fenster
verschiedenen tagen gast in dieser
sendung
er brennt ja für seine sache nötig ihnen
dass das respekt ab wie er für seine
sache brennt wir dafür eintritt
ich kann es nicht sagen also das wäre
gelogen wenn ich das sage es benötigt
mir respekt ab
ich habe seine frau im uhr
die gesagt hat die sagte er ich bin
eigentlich die biologin und er hat
eigentlich nur health management
studiert und hat dass sie eine abrede
gestellt so eine qualifikation also das
muss man dahin gestellt
aber ich finde die ich finde es sehr
naja haben was falsches sagen menschen
also es ist ja so man muss nicht
unbedingt inhalieren oder trinken man
kann zum beispiel auch wie seinen
dauerlauf oder so führt auch zur sucht
erscheinung wir wissen von joschka
fischer und ich glaube er ist in einem
rhythmus drin wo das schon nur eine
sucht befriedigt wird also karl
lauterbach ist wirklich allgegenwärtig
in dieser krise aber er bestimmt nicht
die richtlinien der kroner politik das
mal eine andere die gucken
[Musik]
frau merkel sie sind bundeskanzlerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland
antwort c das war noch keine frage sie
sehen aber viele anders und werden bald
ihre kanzlerschaft beenden also dann
nehme ich doch antwort a
frau merkel ich stelle grad und auch
keine fragen ich stelle nur fest
es ändert ja nichts meinen antworten
aller bitte dann wollen wir mal schauen
ob von ihren antworten eine dabei ist
mario wir heute beginnen mit wer war
millionär
denn wir starten heute mit einer million
und wollen einmal schauen ob auch hier
sie das geld anderer verzocken durch
falsche politik durch falsche geraten
das heißt jetzt verzocken wissen sie wie
viel geld den leuten zukommen lassen
oder weil sie das bestreiten die so
drauf sind
antwort es die antwort gibt's auch gar
nicht das wollte ich damit ausdrücken
verstehe nicht was sie meinen
ich verstehe ich was sie meinen das ist
immer gut
frau merkel erste frage also
[Musik]
mit welchem satz unterstützt die
bundeskanzlerin die nachfolgende
generation wenn sie den 314 milliarden
neuverschuldung stop von finanzminister
olaf scholz abbezahlen muss scholz
schafft uns wie wir schaffen das frohes
schaffen oder die wehr geht anschaffen
ich nehme b ist es ernst frau merkel
diese antwort gibt es gar nicht ja aber
sie stimmt leider falsch und frau merkel
die einfach ist die wir siegen auf
250.000 ja zu viel verdienen die meisten
im ganzen leben nicht
[Applaus]
angela merkel angela möglich ist ja seit
vielen vielen jahren wahrscheinlich für
an den kabarettisten und parodisten wie
sie die die wichtigste rolle
wie haben sie sich das denn an
geeigneten die figur wie ich mir alle an
eigene also ich habe zum glück irgendwie
beobachtungsgabe die ganz gut
funktioniert ich habe ein regisseur der
mich ganz gut kontrolliert den günther
berlin mit dem ich seit 100 jahren
zusammenarbeite und es ist wie beim
zahnarzt auch nur kurz auf die c3 ist
nicht ganz so laut und so kann ich sehr
schnell irgendwie eine figur agra
erfassen worauf kommt woran gesten
kleidung oder müssen sich personen
hineinversetzen hinein fühlen denken wie
sie das geht schnell also eine figur
anzuhören und dann merke ich ich höre
sie ein paar minuten an und dann merke
ich schon dass ich in dem spiel schon
schreibe das andere ist eine ist
eigentlich hat zu tun mit einer
wiedererkennbarkeit bei den menschen
auch eine figur ihn eine frau wie merkel
war am anfang nicht so erkennbar wie
sich jetzt ist weil sie hat jeden tag im
fernsehen ist und jeder weiß ihre
bewegungen kennt und ihre abläufe kennt
und so in ihre reaktion ihrer sprache
kennen also am anfang nicht so gewesen
und da ist es dann wichtig
charakteristika zu finden die diese
figur sein könnte sie haben sich ja
richtig in sich rein versetzt werden sie
irgendwie uns vermitteln wie angela
merkel tickt ich kann es verstehen einer
kleinen episode erklären die deutlich
macht wie auch ihre politik läuft ich
habe einmal die gelegenheit sie zu ihr
gehabt sie zu treffen
und ganz kurz nur und da da ich begrüße
sie jetzt ja eh auf sie zu und sage frau
merkel schon montag sie werden mich
nicht kennen
also es war ein nicht klein ganz
deutliches nein aber kein klar geäußert
es nein dann konnte beschließen sie
kennt mich nicht worauf er zu ihr sagte
ich spiele sie manchmal in meinen
sendungen worauf sie sagte ja ich weiß
das sagt eine ganze menge erstmal die
kante
sie kannte mich aber hat erstmal
geleugnet und weißwasser woraufhin aus
das nein was sie äußerte war auch nicht
so deutlich dass man hier unterstellen
konnte sie sagte nein und dann liest
dann harmlos rausgehen konnte sanken
bekannt es gibt ja eine ganze menge
kritik an der politik von angela merkel
in der flüchtlingskrise jetzt in dieser
krise trotzdem angela merkel steht nach
wie vor relativ unangefochten an der
spitze der regierung und ist derzeit
deutschlands beliebteste politikerin
haben sie dann erklären also jetzt
einige siege damit zusammen weil sie
selber eine sehr bescheidene frau ist
man kann ihr keine korruption nach sagen
und man kann nicht sagen dass sie was
wir an eigenen vorteil tut und so weiter
das ist sicher das eine was den leuten
auch immer wieder klar wird und das
zweite ist
dass sie aus der flüchtlingskrise sehr
gut gelernt hat indem sie bei der
flüchtlingskrise hat daher gesagt das
volk weiß nichts wir wissen alles jetzt
sagen wir das volk weiß nix wir wissen
auch nicht so wenn sie da auf die bühne
gehen und ihr programm machen im moment
ist ihr programm auch völlig dominiert
wie alles gelesen von arona haben sie da
eine bestimmte absicht ein bestimmtes
ziel wollen sie eine bestimmte haltung
oder einstellung vermitteln aber
vermitteln wie ich sie sicher aber ein
ziel habe ich nicht also ich glaube das
falscheste was man in meinem job tun
kann ist dass man moral verbreitet und
hoffe die leute denken also wie man
selbst das sollte nicht sein
ich habe eine gewisse tendenz kann ich
ihren bühnenprogramm er das wahre wesen
und das ist nicht so ganz
unterschiedlich zu dem was sie zu beginn
der sendung gesagt haben die
verlängerung hat aber das dient dazu das
die leute selber drüber nachdenken also
ich möchte sagen wir erstmal
formulierungshilfen geben es gibt
oftmals situationen wo die menschen
kommen nach der forschung sagen ach wie
sie wir haben schon so gedacht wie sie
aber wir konnten es nicht ausdrücken
und das zweite ist anschließend zu geben
das heißt auch dass man gegenteiliger
meinung sein muss oder kann um dann eine
synthese für sich selbst zu finden also
dazu ist ein programm da und es ist
natürlich auch dazu unterhalten also
auch über die höhe das lachen
transportiert sie eine ganze menge auch
an eigenen erkenntnisse
jetzt sind sie ein relativ bekannte und
dezidierte kritiker der politik waren
das schon über die ganze partie hinweg
da hat es auch ziemlich wirbel mal
gegeben als sie ihre kritik bei
maischberger geäußert haben sind sie
prinzipiell der ansicht dass man in
deutschland nicht richtig umgeht mit
kritik an der korona politik das darf
ich so nicht sagen weil ich habe ihn in
dem sender nämlich produzieren da ist
wäre da kann ich da habe ich nie
irgendetwas erfahren was ich nicht sagen
durfte dass das an und das zweite es ist
er wenn sie sagen man kann nicht alles
oder wenn es menschen gibt die sagen ich
kann nicht alles sagen
hängt das er mit der schere im kopf
zusammen zusammen die
hat also wer weiß wie ich jetzt wie ich
jetzt angegriffen werde wenn ich das
sage aber ist aber eine die die eigene
selbstkontrolle eher als dass es von
außen gott also als das ist dass man
sagt man kann die meinung nicht mehr
sagen
also dieser an sich bin ich nicht und
ich habe was jetzt was aber wenn sie das
ansprechen mit der mit krone auffällig
war am anfang vor einem jahr oder wie es
anfing mit corinna zeit dass man egal
was man sagt ich habe mich immer berufen
auf die fakten die ich offiziell von
frau merkel von lkw und der eu bekommen
und so und trotzdem gleichwohl wenn ich
mich dann so geäußert habe wie gerade in
der sendung hieß es dann von
merkwürdigen kritiken
es wären also crew die ideen also wissen
was heute inzwischen weil die leute
einfach nicht mehr können seit 6 8
wochen sich wirklich auch auf breiter
ebene ändert sie lesen heute sehr viel
mehr kritik an den maßnahmen der
regierung oder über den umgesetzten
maßnahmen oder noch nicht umgesetzte
maßnahmen als vor einem halben jahr das
ist deutlich zu merken und und auch von
von seriösen magazin also das muss man
schon sagen das war völlig persönlich
heute mit mathias richling herzlichen
dank ich danke auch bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]